[Music]
let's try and play with the new
pongfinity racket case
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
good for our alternates as well
next challenge is to play with two nets
on one and a half tables let's go
this is gonna take forever though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good footwork training
this is one of those challenges that
we've had it in mind for a long time but
we've sort of avoided it because it
seems like a bad idea
no
good that the table was there because
otherwise i would have
slammed on the floor
that was my roller skate celebration
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful thank you
next challenge we're going to make a
bouncy ball out of rubber bands
first stage the small bouncy ball
oh it goes so easily over do your
hardest smash
that's quite scary yeah
nice
oh that's gonna be tough
should we make it bigger let's make it
bigger
[Music]
so the final stage
of the rubber band ball well let's try
it's quite a big if you compare it to
the racket size
[Music]
oh
oh that sounded bad
i think i heard a crack in my racket
[Music]
yeah i think that's enough with the
giant ball
it was fun to try out though it was
interesting to try out but i'm not sure
about the fun
last week we launched a new mobile game
pongfinity jewels go and check it out
it's a really cool online game where you
can even challenge your friends download
it for free from the links in the
description until next time